call of duty games can sometimes
contradict themselves the franchise
dictates that each new game has a
specific feel things like quick kill
times and consistent approaches to
movement and weapons and campaigns that
mix a large sense of scale with an
individual intensity of battle call of
duty vanguard maintains all of these
things but it also strains under the
formula it climbs to some excellent
heights but stumbles often along the way
as well what the bloody hell is he doing
vanguard returns to world war ii but
takes a fictionalized exaggerated
approach to the conflict it puts you in
the shoes of four veteran heroes as they
come together to form the first modern
special forces team the story can be a
bit cartoonish at times it feels like
call of duty's take on something like
the expendables but it's also fitting
for a game where you single-handedly
kill hundreds of enemies in each mission
these folks are the best of the best and
the story takes you through flashbacks
for each one establishing why they're
the best and then letting them work
together to hijack a nazi train and
smash a nazi base creating memorable
characters and leaning into storytelling
is an area the franchise has often
struggled with and much of what makes
the campaign fun is how vanguard goes on
building your team it's all character
all the time that helps keep the story
from getting disjointed as it leaps
around both the timeline of the war and
the globe dropping you in major battles
so you can see how each character got to
where you find them but it's in those
moments of character development that
the vanguard half of the game struggles
against the traditional call of duty
half the campaign is built on
introducing each of your team's
characters with their own missions
sending you to various world war ii
theaters in an attempt to deliver a
variety of experiences in a variety of
locations it's hit and miss though
vanguard wants to make each of the
characters feel like a specialist by
giving them different abilities but not
all the ideas attached to them work
especially well the standout of the
campaign is paulina a russian sniper and
hero of the battle of stalingrad paulina
is more agile than the other characters
allowing her to quickly sneak under
tables and through tight spaces or climb
walls to get to sniper perches when
she's not sniping her missions are
largely about stealth as she sneaks
through bombed out buildings to slip
behind enemy soldiers and knife them in
the neck before disappearing among the
debris their exciting and fraught
moments but her character-specific
ability flashing a knife to coax a
sniper into wasting a shot so she can
spot them
is only useful in very specific
instances it really just allows you to
kill specific enemies when they show up
and so feels less like a skill and more
like a button you push at the designated
time
other missions and characters are less
interesting and less distinct lucas an
explosives expert fighting german tank
battalions in north africa pretty much
fights the same way as british team
leader and paratrooper arthur or
american pilot wade jackson lucas's
special ability is carrying lots of
different kinds of grenades and when
it's his time to shine he mostly just
throws grenades
similarly arthur can order other
teammates to focus fire on certain
targets sometimes suppressing them but
there's no real strategy involved most
of the time you only have one or two
options so when a target shows up you
tell your team to shoot at it until you
can flank it and kill it if they stop
shooting you just repeat the process
wade's chunk of the game is the weakest
with the digression to an airborne
mission over the pacific that mixes
confusing objectives with loose controls
and boring dogfights when he's not in a
plane wade has the strange focus ability
that lets him detect enemies through
walls and underbrush for a short period
but using it doesn't afford you any
interesting iterations on the combat
you've been playing through for hours by
that point wade's ability is primarily
deployed for sneaking past enemies
during his mission but it's never clear
how or why enemies detect you leading to
a much more irritating stealth section
where you just stay as far away from
everyone as the linear path will allow
it all amounts to a campaign that has
its exciting highlights but doesn't
really achieve the goal of making it
feel like you're experiencing different
aspects of world war ii or taking on the
roles of characters with particular
skills the opportunities to use specific
abilities are heavily prescribed and the
campaign itself is extremely linear in
the usual call of duty way with some
moments and elements scripted so
specifically that it can make the game
feel more like a ride than a war
competitive multiplayer fares better
although vanguard's attempts at focusing
on character also struggle against the
call of duty framework on that side of
the experience as well you can choose
from a number of different operator
characters to play in multiplayer
including characters from the campaign
but the nature of the call of duty
player vs player experience demands that
they all have the same capabilities so
the emphasis placed on the operators
they even all get their own special
cutscenes when you choose them really
doesn't amount to much more than
opportunities to earn new character
skins the additions to multiplayer
though are positive ones even if they're
mostly iterative changes to the familiar
maps are littered with destructible
walls giving you chances to bust out new
sight lines or shoot people through
flimsy cover the destruction adds
pathways and tactical options while also
increasing the overall chaos as bullets
fly from more places that makes
multiplayer matches feel like they
change over time which brings a fun
dynamism to battles that requires you to
think quickly and adjust your approach
vanguard also features some new modes
and adjustments that enhance the usual
multiplayer fare the competitive menu
includes a new option that lets you tune
the kind of matches you want to play
leaning into either large team battles
on bigger maps or smaller more intense
firefights that get you into the action
more quickly the patrol mode is a
highlight adding mobility to control
points that forces you to constantly
chase them around the map which further
adds to the dynamic feel of battles and
incentivizes out-of-the-box thinking to
catch opponents unaware there's also
champion hill which mixes the high speed
low player count intensity of modern
warfare's gun game with elements of
warzone champion hill pits teams of
either two or three players against each
other in a round robin competition where
each team has a set number of lives and
earns money from kills that money can
then be spent on perks new weapons and
upgrades and armor to give you an edge
but the speed of battle means that
winning a fight usually comes down to
smart movement and good team play it's a
fun iteration on call of duty ideas that
already work which resulted in a lot of
heart competitive moments in our
multiplayer sessions
champion victory is yours
along with a heavy emphasis on building
fun weapon loadouts with the gunsmith
menu the tweaks here give vanguard a
feeling of heightened customization and
fluidity presenting you with a chance to
seek out the kind of call of duty
experience you like most weapon unlocks
also transfer between modes which
lessens the grind needed to expand your
arsenal a lot of vanguard's multiplayer
offerings feel like the usual call of
duty fair so if you already like what
you've been playing in modern warfare or
black ops cold war you'll probably like
this too though the tweaks aren't
necessarily all huge they're solid
adjustments that bring new variety to
the series overall
where vanguard brings bigger changes is
in the perennial zombies mode although
part of that experience is currently
missing zombies has been a fascinating
addition to the series as a sort of
horde mode puzzle box that players have
to survive as well as solve but that
mode can be tough to understand with
little guidance as you work through it
black ops cold war developer treyarch
returned to work on the mode and it
streamlines zombies in a lot of smart
ways you now load into the mode in a
central hub area where you can upgrade
your character as you earn points from
killing enemies from the central area
you advance by activating portals that
take you to areas with specific
objectives like holding out for a few
minutes in a tight room as it fills with
zombies or gathering runes dropped by
dead enemies the objectives are clear
and well-defined something that's not
always true in zombies as you complete
those objectives you advance through
waves of enemies which become more and
more difficult while also unlocking more
parts of the hub area so you can access
additional upgrades vanguard's take on
the mode is friendly to new players
interested in checking out one of the
weirdest and coolest additions to the
franchise the clarity deliberate pacing
and obvious goals make it a lot of fun
even if you're not a die hard the
trouble is that at launch zombies lacks
that puzzle box feeling that made it so
endearing to begin with the
story-centric easter eggs and secrets
that usually define zombies are being
added with vanguard's first content
season which launches on december 2nd
until then however zombies feels a bit
lacking compared to past games it can be
fun to see how long you can last as the
waves get tougher and tougher but
there's nothing in the way of an
overarching goal at the moment that
makes zombies feel more like a passing
distraction before you hop back into pvp
or wrap up the campaign
you're safe ah fantastic
rest now
we live to fight another day and that's
sort of the overarching issue with
vanguard things don't feel like they
quite synergize the adjustments to
zombies make it more approachable but
the mode is currently missing what makes
it worth diving into over and over the
campaign's focus on characters gives the
story some impact but it falls flat in
trying to make most of the characters
feel special and distinct competitive
multiplayer brings some adjustments to
the overall formula that make the game
feel more dynamic but they're all mostly
small steps forward the thing about call
of duty games is that with each yearly
iteration you pretty much know what
you're getting and that's largely the
case here it's both a blessing and a
curse for vanguard elements of the game
feel like really good additions to the
franchise but its ideas also don't
always mix well with the framework that
framework is still strong and the solid
gunplay exciting multiplayer and
inventive moments of the campaign are
worth seeking out but forcing those two
parts together exposes some of the seams
in call of duty vanguard weakening both
parts of the game rather than pushing
either one to the forefront
thus you're teaching me how to shoot
wasted
in a med tent
don't be in a rush to fight dodging
glory is worth nothing
when you are dead